i think magnus
had some
crushing results against him then so if
he can find back to that form um it
could be
a good finish to today for for magnus
all right ding ding ding it's what we
hear david the game has started and what
are we seeing we're seeing this sicilian
defense one of the most popular openings
in chess but also from black one of the
most counter-attacking openings in chess
and magnus hasn't handled it in the
traditional way he's putting his own
personal stamp on this opening white
queen coming out very early we normally
recommend not to do this definitely
don't try this at home especially if
you're first starting out the game white
queen now attacked by the black knight
is going to have to retreat queens are
the most valuable pieces so you need to
save them for later any time the queen
is attacked she has to retreat because
she's always going to get hit by lower
valued pieces in the open sicilian it's
one of the most fighting ways to handle
the position and i think magnus is going
to do that over the next two or three
turns this opening with white is really
really dynamic
already there's an imbalanced pawn
structure especially if as mentioned
both kings castle and opposite flanks
that in chess that's one of the most
kind of double-edged things we'll see
black start to develop pieces now as
well
starting with this dark square bishop on
a great diagonal pride and joy and uh
okay magnus not committing his king yet
but this type of idea is typical we see
a trade here you'd never ever want to
capture white's bishop because this
would allow the white queen
in the vicinity of your king and now
there will be checkmating ideas all over
the place this black king lacking
defenders only one real defender this
night and that's not gonna be enough on
the dark squares so often you delay it
and delay it and delay it as long as
possible because then your opponent
can't commit the attack yet if white
went on the attack on one side then the
black king maybe would run to the other
side of the board so that's why they're
playing with pieces ah very good
question ivanka i guess once you've said
a you normally say b and okay he does
commit his king if black's bishop did
run away from a potential trade then
you've moved your bishop twice in the
opening you don't normally want to move
the same piece twice
so you're right white definitely will be
tempted now to use the knight and
capture black's light squared bishop
but knights and bishops worth roughly
the same it's not clear that that
necessarily benefits white yet uh that
black can organize against white's king
and there we go and uh black yet to
organize an attack but white is ready if
that pawn pushes one square further
forward white's rook in the corner is
ready or ready to join the attack and
actually maybe even decide the game in
all types of positions all types of
random positions that pawn is whizzing
up the board and causing trouble now
and uh okay meanwhile duda centralizes
his night
anyway anytime any against anything and
uh okay we do have some moves because
that uh h pawn harry has found itself on
the fifth row i mean that is so whoa
look that is scary each one yeah and
it's now gone and now you can see as
david highlighted that rook in the
corner that now has a nice open line and
uh all white needs to do now is start
attacking along the dark squares but now
this rook is on a completely he has done
this it's on a completely open line
towards the black king now all you need
to do is really eliminate this defender
and then there's going to be checkmating
ideas all over the place we could see a
checkmate in under 20 moves unless okay
he's actually gone for this magnus
carlsen uh yeah unless dude is really
coming up with some genius defense i
think we're going to see magnus just
crush this game and we meet in half an
hour and then we decide or take the
meeting outside in the park
even better better ah
wow whoa and where did magnus go and
what happens to the bar yeah um dude
just retreating his bishop actually the
bishop came from this square a few moves
ago so that doesn't help black's
position at all um white does have a
winning advantage now but magnus is he
disconnected yeah that's yeah if he is
is he gonna get back into the idea
behind that move is to actually free up
this square for the black knight the
knight trying to jump in to attack the
white queen attack the white dark square
bishop but this is very logical as we
mentioned several times already the
bishop does jump in magnus has played
this this is the key defender black's
dart squad bishop and once you remove
that there's going to be checkmating
ideas all over the place and he can also
just castle his king but i would keep
things simple and he does do that taking
this bishop
and
yeah i'm expecting to see some clever
moves by magnus but he will surely
finish this one off yeah and a lot of
enjoyment for everyone because we do
enjoy
a well a very convincing attack so now
we're waiting to see whether rook takes
night and it's on the board
it made sense you know just blast open
the king because
um opening lines is like the currency
for attack the more lines that you open
against the king the more vulnerable and
exposed he is so now we're expecting
knight takes night just as you said
that's uh at first i was about to
suggest the white queen jumping in with
the check first but that would have
allowed black's knight to come back and
block so now this move i mean this
series of moves that i mentioned is
actually happening on the board the
other reason magnus can go for this is
because black's king can never escape
the king has to move now and at the very
very minimum there's a safety net for
magnus he could just give checks forever
with his queen and black's king cannot
escape so that would end in a repetition
and a draw
a nice thing just to have in your pocket
and now black's king steps back in this
way and
there we go the bishop moves the white
king is about to evacuate the first rank
or maybe even just castle and then that
white rook in the left-hand corner is
not doing anything but it is going to be
the piece that delivers the killer blue
we're jealous i've never oh never heard
of it you never they sell them here in
norway really yeah oh we have a result
yep young christophe duda has resigned
magnus carlsen is actually shaking his
head but
it is a win for the world champion an
important win for him actually